أحب النظر إلى الصور حتى لو
لم تكن من عائلتي، أخبر القصة
أنه كان طفلًا سعيدًا يا إلهي، لقد
كان سعيدًا جدًا طوال الوقت، كان من الصعب
التحدث عنه، لا، أحب التحدث عنه،
أتحدث عنه  أي شخص يستمع،
أحببت رؤيته في حلبة الهوكي
وأعتقد أن هذا كان حقًا
مكانه السعيد، كما تعلم حيث يمكن أن
يكون حرًا نوعًا ما، حيث
حزم أصدقاؤه على الفور من
المدارس أينما كانوا وجاءوا
وبدأت العائلة  لقد حضرت وكنت
في حالة صدمة، كما تعلم أننا حاولنا
إجراء الإنعاش القلبي الرئوي وليس من المحتمل أن يكون الأمر قد
انتهى منذ فترة طويلة، لا أقول إنه تناول جرعة زائدة، بل أقول
إنه توفي بسبب تسمم الفنتانيل
بصدق كما كان في نهاية اليوم بالنسبة
لي.  قُتل
لأنه طلب شيئًا واحدًا،
فأعطوه شيئًا مختلفًا، وقد أودى بحياته
في ليلة حزينة واحدة في الثاني من نوفمبر،
أصبح ماثيو لودن، ابن دينا، واحدًا من
ما يقرب من 92000 حالة جرعات زائدة قاتلة في
عام 2020 وحده، وكان الكثير منها مدفوعًا
بمشكلة الفنتانيل.  العديد من هذه
الأدوية الموجودة الآن في الشارع والتي
اضطرت إدارة مكافحة المخدرات إلى إنشاء
مختبر سري للطب الشرعي فيها فقط لمحاولة مواكبة ذلك، نحن نشق
طريقنا إلى هناك الآن.
سكوت ألتون هو نائب
المدير المساعد لمكتب إدارة مكافحة المخدرات
لعلوم الطب الشرعي.  نحن نحصل على المزيد من
الحبوب، والمزيد من تلك الحبوب
تعود إيجابية للفنتانيل، نعم
تقريبًا كل واحد منهم
يعود إيجابيًا في عام 2019، ما
يقرب من 2.2 مليون حبة
في عام 2022،
50.6 مليون حبة
في بداية وباء المواد الأفيونية،
العديد من  كانت الحبوب أصلية،
معظم الحبوب التي تم ضبطها اليوم
على الحدود في الشوارع حتى في
المدارس، أكثر من 99 منها مما نراه مزيفة، فهي
تحتوي على فنتانيل 99، هذا فقط هذا هو
رقمي
وانظر عن كثب إلى مدى
تطور المزورين وفقط
على سبيل المثال، هذه بعض
الأشياء التي سنلتقطها والتي لها
نفس M وهي أربعة في 30 على
الجانب الآخر
إذا نظرت إلى ما هو حقيقي هنا
وفنتانيل قوس قزح، فإنهم لم يعودوا
يحاولون إخفاءه بعد الآن  من
الواضح أن هذا مزيف ولكن أيضًا إذا نظرت إلى
800 جرام من الفنتانيل التي تتحول
إلى 400 إلى
500000 حبة من المحتمل أن تكون مميتة، ففكر في
ذلك الكيس الواحد الذي يمنحك 400 إلى 500000
جرعة مميتة، إنها الرسالة التي تريد إدارة مكافحة المخدرات
نشرها هناك حبة واحدة  يمكن أن تقتل
أيام التجارب،
لذا يجب على هذا المختبر المتطور أن يستمر في
محاولة تحليل هذه الحبوب
وصولاً إلى بنيتها الجزيئية باستخدام
ما يعادل جهاز التصوير بالرنين المغناطيسي، لقد
رأينا مئات ومئات من
التركيبات الفريدة لذلك سنرى واحدة بها
يحتوي على الفنتانيل، واحد مع الفنتانيل
وزيلازين، وواحد مع فنتانيل، وكافيين، وواحد
مع فنتانيل وأسيتامينوفين، وأنت
لا تعرف ما الذي تحصل عليه، وما
مدى صعوبة مواكبة كمية
المنتجات المقلدة الموجودة هناك، فالسوق
يتغير باستمرار، لذلك نحن
نحاول أن نفعل كل ما في وسعنا من
قاعدة علمية لمواكبة عملية
القتل هذه، لا تغتنم الفرصة، فالأمر لا
يستحق حياتك، إنها
رسالة تتمنى دينا أن
يسمعها ماثيو، لذا بدلاً من ذلك جعلت من
مهمتها أن تكون صوته  بمجرد أن
تتمكن من
البدء في إجراء هذه المحادثات مع
أطفالك في عمر يمكنهم فيه
فهمها حقًا، أعتقد أن الأمر
يحتاج فقط إلى التحدث عنها، فهي
لعبة الروليت الروسية، فلن تعرف أبدًا
ما الذي ستحصل عليه من
تقارير الدكتور سانجاي جوبتا لشبكة سي إن إن